if you're stuck um let me help you
admittedly you look at that and because
they see square root things by the way
writing it as things to the power of 1/2
I think yes I'm totally in on this and
it doesn't really help at all okay so
what do we do first let's take those
principles and let's see what it equals
in this case okay so you start with the
limit okay
by the way people don't usually start
with move and then forget to put it on
the or stop putting on they usually
forget at the beginning okay so that's
why I'm always going to say and I hope
you've seen your own head start with the
limit okay what's f of X plus h it's
just square root of x potato okay and
then you've got minus f of X which is
that and that's all divided by H now
remember your goal is to get rid of this
H okay but get out of the denominator
somehow now before what we did was we
expanded it was quite simple what we had
to do okay but in other words we
manipulated the numerator so that the H
appeared in common okay so we had to do
something with this guy in order to get
rid of this guy now you've got square
roots okay our squares heard notorious
for being like hard to work with they
don't interact with each other right so
I have to change them into a form that
all allow them to do that to interact
and there's one way which you've learned
in your night namely and what we called
the conjugate right conjugates are
useful because they allow us to take
advantage of differences where come in
in for a moment okay now that I've got
my conjugates there what does it mean
I've got difference of squares up here
right so just in case you can't quite
see it it's a minus B a plus B yes so
when I factorize that it should be a
squared minus B squared right
but because everything's square roots
start with your limit it'll be a squared
minus B squared
okay now this conjugate it doesn't do
anything to the denominator so this is
kind of backwards what were used to
doing we're used to arm you know
rationalizing the denominator I'm kind
of irrational izing the denominator but
it's actually what I want because now I
can work with the numerator these X's
just like over here they cancel right
that X so I've got the limit as H
approaches zero or and these HS here
which are in common
cancel out now you may look at that and
think this is no better than where I
started right it's I've still got these
square roots flying around
well actually it's much better than
where we started because we got rid of
that H on the denominator which was the
problem I can actually put in H equal
zero at this point okay so when H is
zero I've got 1 over the square root of
x plus the square root of x that's 1
over 2 root X now I'd be either usually
happy with that except I just want to
draw the fact that if I wrote this in
index form it would be 1/2 X to the
power of a negative because it's on the
bottom and it's a square root which is
exactly what we're expecting okay so
this rule here
this is an X to the N minus 1 it works
regardless of what number you've got as
n it can
Olmo or it can be a fraction okay